I probably would want to start out my
presentation by just a few couple little
that's first thing that this this actual
paper presentation I'm going to present
to you all yeah it's been in a couple
different formats right now so this is
my effort to sort of tease it out a
little bit and sort of expand on it it
appear to Asia times it appeared the
national interest where I used to be the
executive editor so I know everybody's
very big into attribution these days
that is my effort to do so so probably
one thing that I want to start out with
there's been a lot of different
presentations today that are very
academically orientated uh something
that I'd want to point out about myself
is I am NOT probably traditional
academic I actually got into this field
many years ago before I went to college
I was in marketing i was in
communications went back to school
finished my undergrad went to grad
school and ended up actually being an
assistant editor at the diplomat and
that's sort of how i got very involved
in this field rose to the ranks ended up
with different editorial positions so
when i approached the issues of the
South China Sea and looking at us
strategy of before I became a think
tanker it seems like my mindset never
really shifts away from the media and
thinking about different strategies that
the United States and its regional
allies of partners can utilize that are
sort of media-centric and I think for a
lot of the younger people today we see
the power of social media specifically
and how it can really create narratives
ideas and concepts that can really drive
public opinion in vastly different ways
both positive and negative so that's
sort of the basis of where this
presentation comes from and some of
these different ideas
okay so um the crux do this presentation
that i'm going to talk about a little
bit today is what if we had the power to
change china's power constructs or its
its cost calculations based on using
common technologies we utilize today
think about your cell phone think about
digital cameras things about think about
those things and how those things can be
brought into social media pictures video
all of these things and how they have
the power to change like i said before
public opinion and change that the
narrative of different concepts and what
if we were to utilize that the South
China Sea and much more effective ways
and in much more stronger ways than
we've done in the past so that's sort of
what the crux of this is going to be
about today so sort of think about that
as I sort of move through the
presentation now that the common theme I
think everybody has to do these days is
I have about four different affiliations
at the moment so I have to do that the
legalese and say the views expressed are
my own so just keep that in mind now
before we talk about shame fair and in
the constructs that I'm going to get in
a little bit deeper detail on I think we
need to have a little bit of a very very
quick discussion about a sort of US
policy US foreign policy goals going
back to me about 2011 and moving forward
and then I'm just going to walk through
very quickly China's goals in the South
China Sea which have been elaborated on
quite a bit so i'll move through that
very very quickly so where do we begin i
think obviously the natural place to
start is the the pivot or the rebalance
to Asia very broadly defined in 2011 up
in really it was it was the the
quintessential moment when the United
States was going to redefine its foreign
policy goals in terms of geography which
areas were going to be of most
importance which areas were going to be
of lesser importance we were going to
move away from the different conflicts
in the Middle East we were drawing down
forces in Iraq we were drawing down
forces in Afghanistan and we were sort
of going to move to what the future of
you on foreign policy goals and strategy
was going to be you're going to focus on
trade economic bright spots it's
specifically in the broader indo-pacific
region especially the transfer
the partnership that was going to be
very important and most importantly we
were going to focus on China positive
and negative connotations to that a lot
of it would be basically a hedging
strategy it came to China but also
emphasizing those economic ties we have
to keep in mind that we have old
something like I believe it's a 600
billion dollar bilateral trade
relationship with China that is that is
a lot to work on and a very positive
aspect of the relationship so that was
going to be a focus as well all right
moving forward ah so it was a great plan
I mean it made a lot of sense it was
probably the ultimate bumper sticker
foreign policy slogan there was wide
praise in the media but what what
happened well how did it sort of come
undone or lose its focus at least as how
would I would argue of five very quick
things i would i would argue very fast
uh domestic politics the united states
obviously as we watch the presidential
election today obviously nited states
has great domestic political problems
just going back a few years you think
about the battle over sequestration and
the budget at one point we were actually
talking about the united states that the
superpower of the world actually maybe
defaulting on its on its debt
obligations how are you a superpower if
that is a problem so you can't start
talking about a pivot or rebalance to
Asia if if you're having these sort of
basic debates about whether you're going
to pay your debt or not so think about
that a little bit other sort of foreign
policy problems the rise of Isis which
were confounded with today you know the
United States has to obviously put a lot
of resources and capabilities to try and
contain at least at the moment then try
to defeat Isis there's news reports that
were there in the media widely
circulated last week the United States
had to extend the deployment of an
aircraft carrier there's a lot of
consternation saying we don't have
enough carrier capability so if we're
having problems doing that how do you
pivot to Asia something to keep in mind
Russia's invasion of Ukraine and in
cleaving off of Crimea again it seems
like now the United States is having to
basically pivot back to Europe we're
talking about stationing more men and
materiel and Europe how do you pivot to
Asia when you have to do that at the
same time also we have this challenge of
what I call
red line dilemma us credibility I know
there's a big debate on this not enough
time to get into it but when President
Obama declared that there was a red line
Syria using chemical weapons and then we
didn't do anything about it and I will
admit the options we're not very good to
do something it's never good to do
foreign policy by just doing something
uh what I used to travel through through
Asia a lot more when this happened a lot
of my friends and colleagues in
different countries were questioning our
resolve now you can debate that whether
that's just idle talk but when that
keeps circulating the press it creates
doubts in people's minds and I know that
that's very hard to to judge and what
that all looks like and if that damages
us credibility but I think it's at least
open for debate and then the very last
thing America is a very war weary
country uh we spent billions of dollars
in Iraq and Afghanistan we had many
casualties in those fights we had many
more men and women and servicemen who
bravely served and came back with with
terrible injuries that will cost the
country a tremendous amount of money to
rightly take care of those brave men and
women at the same time the country is
also worried about making another
foreign commitment so I think that's
also something we need to kind of keep
into this calculus ah so quickly euros
priorities have changed now is going go
looking at today and I would say there
are basically three broad issues that
this administration is really looking at
defeating but probably mostly containing
Isis at the moment I think the defeat of
Isis will come in another administration
that's a very hard thing to do and for
another panel ah Russia I think we need
to reinforce NATO but also deter Russian
aggression again taking more resources
from from our ability to do things in
Asia and I think the third issue is
China which all these issues get lumped
in together South China Sea East China
Sea Taiwan then it ends up sort of
falling is to a low third so as all this
is basically happening essentially you
know as the United States basically
turns a little bit away from this this
pivot idea the Chinese are ramping up
their their escalatory in nature in the
South China Sea and I don't have a lot
of time to sort of go through all this
but I think we all know the actions chat
you know all the different challenges in
the East China Sea actually at one point
13 when Chinese scholars were
questioning Okinawa and if that was
really Japanese territory crazy crazy
ideas and then all the different
problems in the South China Sea which
have been talked about by many of the
people in this room Scarborough Shoal
oil rigs billing building what are
essentially military bases in the South
China Sea with anti-ship weapons all
different types of facilities
militarizing these islands and I've got
a list here and probably more weapons to
come and very possibly an air defense
identification zone okay and this has
been talked about before so I move
through this quickly but also China's
anti-access area denial capabilities or
have grown tremendously you know we were
talking about this at the beginning of
2009 and their capabilities have have
grown up dramatically we are one of the
other presenters was talking about the
dong Fong 21d or the carrier killer
missile there's now a one that has even
a larger range the DF 26 so their
capabilities have continued to grow and
to grow and especially if there was ever
some sort of cannock conflict in the
South China Sea over Taiwan over the
East China Sea the United States would
have some very terrible choices that it
would have to make in men material
casualties and one of this is one of the
reasons why the whole air-sea battle
concept came about which is basically
being rewritten into jam GC but it's
creating a cost calculation for the
United States that's very dangerous so
looking at the South China Sea
specifically what are China's goals very
very quickly and very simply others have
talked about this so I'll move fast
obviously it seems like military
domination ah the Chinese basically I
think a very broad goal to dominate this
region and I know some of other speakers
have talked about all the different
things that that why they would be doing
that but I think that's at least very
broadly 102 effective sovereignty over
the South China Sea enforcement of the
nine are now ten dash line Beijing I
don't think has a goal of kicking all
the other countries fishing vessels
Coast Guard vessels out of the South
China Sea entirely but I think it's very
clear that they want to be the dominant
power
then the whole nine or ten dash line
region and do what they can over time
maybe over the next 10 15 years to
slowly push the us out of the region I
think that's broadly the goal okay so
knowing China's goals knowing go us
global priorities at the moment at least
what can the u.s. do effectively in the
South China Sea to put up some
roadblocks to Beijing so it's coercion
isn't as easy to sort of implement
there's a lot of things I think we can
do and I think it's a great time for
this debate I with the rise of god I
shouldn't say his name but Donald Trump
uh there's a jury debate that's
happening in u.s. foreign policy today
and I think that's a healthy thing
forget all the rhetoric and forget all
the talk for a moment i think it's it's
a healthy thing to sort of re-evaluate
our priorities and where we're going to
move forward with the next
administration so i think that's a good
thing to do but knowing that the United
States has all these different
commitments all these different
interests because it is a global
superpower I think when we think about a
u.s. strategy on on the South China Sea
it really needs to be resource light of
non kinetic obviously and make China pay
a price for its actions while trying to
preserve the status quo and of course
taking to account the you know the
eliminate availability of us resources
now important point about shame fair
this is not a complete u.s. strategy i'm
going to be just totally honest and
upfront but part of a larger strategy if
i have enough time i'll try to walk
through that a little bit of that but i
think this is a very important part in a
down payment towards that strategy so
shame fear getting to the bolts and nuts
of this like i said part of a bigger
u.s. strategy ah but i think the thing
that's important is that the United
States before enunciates any strategy on
the South China Sea needs to be very
clear about what its goals and
intentions are but as other countries
China are going to try and spin those
intentions to other things using terms
like containment and other things which
United States it's not trying to do so
I'm just going to read this aloud just
so it sits out there America's most
important goal that it shares with
partners and allies across the
asia-pacific and wider indo-pacific
region is the maintenance of a peaceful
and prosperous status quo that ensures
no
One Nation unilaterally course other
countries or attempt to bend their will
through coercive measures turn near seas
or oceans into territory or use hostile
acts to achieve its aims I think those
are broad things that I think most of
the indo-pacific community can get
behind they're very very positive things
and I think this idea of shame fair it
puts China on the defensive sort of
using this this narrative that we're
going to hope to build I'm going to walk
you through to continually put China on
the Pathet defensive place roadblocks in
place so it is not as easy for them to
course and take over the South China Sea
okay so what exactly ashamed fair
basically in a nutshell it's a
consistent effort by the United States
and its allies and partners to uncover
document and expose China's efforts to
overturn the status quo in the South
China Sea such an effort will be
conducted using various methods and
tools and in various domains ah the way
I came about this is I being an editor
specifically at the national interest in
other places you see the power of
different narratives when you publish
something or see other competitors
publish something and how an idea can
really transform a debate and it led me
thinking if the United States and other
regional partners consistently wove the
tail and show Chinese actions over time
through pictures video different types
of documentation intelligence satellites
there's a lot of ways that we can push
back against the Chinese and make this a
lot more difficult than for them to
control the South China Sea and the big
point is it puts the Chinese on the
defensive and it weaves a narrative of
what they're doing that's very negative
and that's very hard for them to push
back against and legitimately defend so
keep that in mind so there's a few parts
of this and I'll walk you through them
but the first one I think is a term that
we all know called lawfare ah and I
think it's very powerful in the narrow
in in terms of Philippine sue in China
that is a very powerful statement and
brings a lot of attention on the issue
and then when when the when the
arbitration case comes to a head and
either the end of this month or the end
of next month I'm not sure which one it
is different media of different the
ideas on that it really
makes the media really repeat what's
going on in the South China Sea so
irregardless of what happens with that
lawsuit I really think other claimants
specifically Vietnam should really
consider about bringing these their
claims to different international court
bodies now i'm not i'm not an expert in
international law but I know there are
different ways that this could be done
and I know some of our presenters have
sketched it out a little bit but that
would create a very powerful media
narrative of what China is doing and it
will get the media to rego over all of
China's different aggressive actions
within the South China Sea and you
continually leave that narrative over
and over again so I think it's very
important it can be very very useful
Vietnam other countries you could could
sue I think it really would be powerful
in terms of sort of shaming the Chinese
and into sort of maybe halting some of
these actions ah but the really really
true nuts and bolts are the Tao of shame
fair is is really the documentation part
of it and this idea came from from amti
the Asia maritime transparency
initiative that csas which I know a lot
of people in this room really look at on
a daily basis think of the power of
those pictures that amt I put out and
then also CNN later when they did their
over flight of the South China Sea owes
about a year ago around this time it got
the South China Sea and China's Island
reclamation projects on the front page
of the New York Times The Wall Street
Journal the Washington Post and not just
us in this room we're talking about this
issue but literally the entire planet
was talking about it so if that effort
could be amplified and I'll give a
couple examples anytime really that the
United States the Philippines Vietnam
anybody who has sort of some stake in
the South China Sea what they really
need to be doing is is using different
types of recording devices to record
what the Chinese are doing and there's
lots of ways to do this you could put
recording vessels on on fauna vessels
that are going out there you could put
them on Vietnamese fishing boats you
could put them on filipino fishing boats
Coast Guard vessels Allied aircraft that
might be going through the area and what
you need to do is anytime there's any
sort of negative interact
you post it online you post it on to
facebook you post on to Twitter you
posted onto Instagram and all the
different iterations of these different
types of things that are through Asia
and it begins to weave this narrative of
what's happening in the South China Sea
now this has done just been done very
lightly by MTI and some of the other
news stories that have come out there
but I think this can be a very powerful
tool considering how how much social
media is permeated through our society I
mean that's how the younger generation
of Millennials are getting their news
and I think if we can really leverage
that it could be a helpful tool i'm not
i'm not going to say that that it would
completely stop the Chinese I definitely
think that would put them on the back
foot it's something they would have to
consider and they'd really have to
consider their actions now another part
of this and I'm going to 0 and
specifically on scroll ball shawl
considering all the talk these days
about it is I really think the United
States needs to make a much more defined
effort in capturing what is happening at
Scarborough Shoal i know i believe was
Admiral Harris who had a report about a
month ago that started this that there
was the possibility that the Chinese
were going to start reclaiming scroll
ball shawl I think the quote that was in
the newspapers was that there was fear
that there was dredging vessels near
there or possibly near there so what I
would have said to Admiral Harris was is
if that's the case and you have
intelligence and it's not going to
compromise United States intelligence
gathering release the photos I guarantee
you those photos would be circulated all
through Asia they'd be circulated
through the newspapers and they again
they push that narrative of what the
Chinese is doing and it forces them to
respond I mean we've all watched some of
the different clumsy Chinese press
conferences of you know stating you know
their their their regional hegemony or I
can't think of the exact terms but if
you can keep pushing them back I think
that's that's very very important things
to do and I think you need to keep the
pressure on them and I think that's
strategically important ah something
else I think that's important and this
has come out a little bit more in the
last couple of weeks something I call
the brain p strategy obviously when you
reclaim islands when you dredge massive
areas to build ports and all these type
of things you basically have to destroy
the ecosystem around those
it's now I'm not an environmental expert
but it that seems like pretty clear and
pretty basic uh so one thing I think the
United States to do along with its
allies and partners is really speak out
on this issue and if we have
intelligence and in satellite
reconnaissance that can show some of
this it might be hard to do but I think
it's out there release the photos
there's nothing more powerful than
documentation to show the world what's
going on and then keep sort of weaving
that narrative I think that would be
very be a very powerful thing and this
has come out quite a bit but I think
it's something that needs to be pushed
more now I do have a little bit of time
left so I can get to this which I'm
happy about so shame fear has to be part
of a much more comprehensive u.s.
strategy to Chinese to halt Chinese
coercion and there's a couple things we
can do there's quickly six things that I
would point to I think the follow-up
operations they need to continue there
was going to be a third one according to
press reports and it was cancelled and I
know there's been a lot of debate on why
that was done I think that was a mistake
I think we need to continue that as part
of a bigger strategy I think it
oppresses the idea that freedom of
navigation is of the United States is
going to continually press upon China
but also other claimants in the South
China Sea and globally it's been part of
us strategy for a long time anytime you
cancel something like that it obviously
sends a very mixed message when I kind
of put my my editor or communications
hat on so I think that was a bad mistake
we need to continue that I number two it
looks like there's overflights now if
Scarborough Shoal using a tens
helicopters other things from the latest
count i have there's at least spend four
of them that have been publicly released
think we need to continue that shows the
united states is certainly invested in
that in that in that part where China
might reclaim and it shows them that
we're taking a stand I think that's
something that needs to continue onward
the other thing I would argue and I've
argued this in other tables before is
that china is not the only country that
can do anti-access area-denial it's I
mean it's an old term is the Japanese
used it during World War Two you can go
back to ancient times I believe there
are references to it and through cities
and other books if you if really break
down the strategies so there are lots of
different ways that we can we can push
back one way would be to arm Vietnam
that's American equipment is obviously
very expensive but there's a lots of
different asymmetric weapons and tools
that could be bought from the Russians
from us and others that could sort of
turn that a to ad cap goes on China's
head um the other thing I would argue is
that if this continues on and China
keeps pressing its claims in the South
China Sea other countries specifically
the United States and others can change
the status quo in the South China Sea do
with Taiwan Relations could be enhanced
dramatically with Taiwan there's the
Taiwanese or is begging for more
military equipment we have lots of
different tools at our disposal to push
back against Beijing so I think it's
something we need to think about Oh
number 5 is very low hanging fruit why
is China invited to RIMPAC when all of
these different things are going on I
understand that the rationale that we're
hoping that China will be a responsible
stakeholder and a part of the
international community really from 2008
on that hasn't been the case so why are
we going to to invite them to this
prestigious international grouping and
naval affair when they're doing all
these things so I think that's something
that needs to happen oh the last one is
one that I don't hope that isn't
considered but if to trend lines
continue I think the United States
really needs to have a bigger much
larger conceptual conversation within
its foreign policy community of really
rethinking the us-china relationship on
a much grander scale that means in terms
of our diplomacy with Beijing and
getting much tougher also means economic
ties to might have to be on the table I
know that's controversial but that's if
China continues pushing on like this and
eventually declares an eight is in the
South China Sea other other coercive
measures we have to start thinking about
about larger steps so I'm going to poke
a hole in my proposal here cuz I think
that's important how is china agree
going to react obviously with with
losing face in Asian communities being
something that you don't want to do or
push I think the Chinese are going to
push back and push back probably pretty
hard there's a report today in VOA news
that the Chinese basically said if the
United States and others
South China Sea push the Chinese going
to push back even harder that is a very
strong possibility but I would argue the
United States in its timid approach
towards towards the South China Sea has
not worked and I think that there really
needs to be a recalibration of our
efforts so I'm basically out of time but
I would just throw this out there even
if you don't like this concept I think
we there's there's a very broad argument
that can be made that the u.s. approach
right now is not working um we need to
really think about Boulder greater ideas
that are of course non kinetic but that
can use the power of the media and other
tools to really push back on the Chinese
to put up some roadblocks that they'll
be much more difficult to get past and I
think using the media and social media
and other tools could be one of those
thank you